à marioupol le bruit des bombes et
incessants dans les rues désertées au
milieu des immeubles détruits cet homme
emmène avec lui sur un chariot tout ce
qu'il a pu sauver
je n'ai plus de maison
elle a été détruite dans un bombardement
peu d'image parviennent de ce port
stratégique assiégée par les russes
les attaques se poursuivent comme sur
cet immeuble résidentiel où les pompiers
parviennent à extraire cette femme
découvre
ici les habitants font la queue pour
récupérer un peu d'eau on a plus d'eau
potable dans nos appartements il fait 10
12 degrés on n'a pas de gaz il fait très
froid il n'y a rien à manger et nanterre
décor dans les jardins des immeubles cet
effrayant on ne tarde à vivre comme ça
selon le chef de la diplomatie
ukrainienne plus de 1500 civils ont été
tués en deux jours les organisations
humanitaires craignent une tragédie si
la situation dure